tina how you feeling today i'm good
thank you
how are you hanging on hanging on you
know
um let's get right into it earlier in
the week you seem really confident that
your top five spot was
solid um but then last night of course
you told orisa that you thought that you
were the target from the get-go so
why is that um you know
kiefer at one point had a conversation
with everyone uh
he was asked about the potential of
putting me up he said he never put me on
the block tara also said that she would
never put me on the block
so i think they looked at our trio as me
being the middle person
eliminate that person and then that
leaves tara in a
vulnerable situation and then keep her
then more loyal to the boys right
um his appointment to the so block as a
replacement nominee was still
pretty emotional right um how do you
think that he managed to save himself
um you know i think at the end of the
day he uh
possibly made a um a final deal with jed
for final two and then a final three
with beth
um and then i think they just
essentially swayed the votes
right now your eviction also marks the
end of the era of tnt
um tell me a bit about your relationship
with tara
uh you know what tara is a great person
uh she was great to have in the house
you know we formed a bond early on um
we were just our our best friends within
the house
uh we could laugh together cry together
um so it was it was it was a nice break
from the game what do you think it was
that gravitated you towards each other
uh you know what i think it was our our
age and our
our stage of life that we're in um that
definitely kind of
started the bond you know we poke fun
at some of the things um you guys did
get really emotional
or sorry tara got really emotional
during the veto competition this week
what was going through your mind when
that was happening how are you feeling
about that
you know what uh i was very proud of
tara
uh getting that moment um the
anniversary of her brother's death was
was coming uh within that that kind of
time frame
and it was something that she really
wanted to do in memory of of him
uh so for her to get that moment i was
super proud of her
right um in the hoh room this week with
beth and jed
uh you told them that you would have
considered putting tara down down the
road putting up putting her up down the
road
um was that legit were you kind of
telling them what you thought they
wanted to hear
i basically told them what they wanted
to hear um and i think they knew that at
the end of the day i
would never have put tara up on the
block she was my she was my girl
right um you did have a close
relationship with keith though it seemed
uh how did you feel about being up on
the block with him
uh you know what it's never good to be
up again up on the block
with uh someone you're closely connected
to um
at the end of the day uh you know i
really
it sucked being up next to him it really
did um
but you know it's big brother uh you're
gonna be put up against
your allies that's what's gonna happen
right well speaking of allies there was
a really strong alliance between beth
jed and ty do you think the rest of the
house can overtake that trio
i do i've had a couple of conversations
with kiefer before leaving the house
um you know basically told them that you
know he needs to
uh he needs to switch his alliance uh or
his allegiance to certain people
i think uh at the end of the day you're
gonna have kiefer
uh kiefer uh tara and braden i think are
gonna band together and um
i'm hoping they'll take a shot now
you're of course headed off to jury
is there anything that you're looking
forward to about that experience
uh you know what it's going to be very
relaxing
um it's just to be able to get away from
the game and have some sort of
normalcy will be great totally
now big brother is still known for lying
deceit
backstabbing um do you think that when
you get to watch this season back that
anyone in the house will surprise you
when you watch things back in terms of
that
those elements oh absolutely uh
you're in that house you never know who
you can trust um
and likely everyone might surprise me
um this season also did have a really
wide range of house guests
um how did it feel to be part of such a
representative cast
if you know what hands down it was the
best selection
cast this year um and i'm super proud
and honored to have been a part of that
um
hands down it was fantastic one last
question for you
at this present moment based on
everything that you saw and experienced
in the house
who do you think most deserves your jury
vote right now kiefer
how so he's played a well-rounded game
he's
great socially he's uh having great
discussions
great game talks he's got comp wins
uh he's just a well-rounded player and
uh he would get my vote right now
amazing well thanks so much tara and i
hope that the jury house is as relaxing
as you hope it is
thanks a lot
you